okay today's video is about annoying
puzzles and i want to start with what i
think is possibly the most annoying
puzzle in the world so it's a simple
enough question just imagine the
department for transport is looking at a
road layout and they've got two
different possibilities for the road
layout and they're trying to figure out
which one is going to cause the fewest
accidents so let me just set out the
possibilities okay this is road layout a
this is road layout b okay very easy now
both of them are predicted
to have a certain number of major
accidents major accidents this is going
to put people in hospital we're talking
broken bones you know serious stuff
there's also a certain number of minor
accidents that might just be like a bit
of first aid you might need to see a
doctor cut some scrapes that sort of
thing okay it's really simple
each of these different road layouts is
going to cause a certain number of major
and minor
road accidents and i just want you to
fill in this gap here so here we go two
thousand
one thousand
sixteen now what goes here to make these
two schemes equivalent
it feels like eight
doesn't it feel like eight doesn't it
feel like eight so this puzzle
comes from shane frederick who's a
behavioral economist psychologist at
yale university yale university they're
smart at yale university and he asked a
whole bunch of yale university students
what the answer was and the most common
number was a bit more than a quarter of
them said eight the next most common
answer was
32
and the next most common answer was if i
remember rightly 1016.
let's have a think about what's going on
here road layout a is going to cause 2
000
major accidents this is people in
hospital oh and 16 people with bumps and
bruises okay so why do we even care
about this
rollout b is going to cause only a
thousand major accidents so
that's much better so
how many minor accidents
would make it equivalent to to road
layout a and the reason this is annoying
question is because there's no there is
no right answer but it's got to be like
a lot it's got to be many thousands
surely many thousands because these are
trivial accidents and these are
substantial and a very small number of
people in shade frederick's survey did
say
a hundred thousand a million and there's
no right answer but it's gotta be
something like that but so many just
like you brady the majority of people
all the the largest minority of people
uh more than a quarter of people said oh
we think
that
the correct answer is eight
and when you look at this you your mind
is wanting you to say eight right
because it's like it just puts
everything in the same proportion right
same you've been asked make these the
same that's the same this is a an
example it's quite a quite a fascinating
example quite a complicated example
of something that shane frederick
studies which he calls cognitive
reflection problems and they were made
famous by the psychologist daniel
kahneman in his book thinking fast and
slow but this one is not in thinking
fast and slow so this one is
this has barely seen the light of day
and i find it fascinating but um
another example this one's made very
famous by thinking fast and slow is a
bat and a ball together cost a dollar
ten and the bat costs a dollar more than
the ball so how much does the bat cost
you may well have heard this before a
lot of people have uh and instinctively
you just think well it's a dollar right
because because the bat costs a dollar
more than the the ball
how much does they cost a dollar ten
together so it's like a dollar and but
that's not right because that's 90 cents
and in fact the correct answer is the
ball costs five cents the bat costs a
dollar and five cents but people leap to
the wrong answer
um you want more oh yeah this is a
classic easier in the time of
coronavirus imagine a lake that is
filling with lily pads has his patch of
lily pads on the lake and the patch
doubles in size every day and after 48
days the lake is completely covered so
the question is on what day
out of the 48 days on what day is the
lake half covered
and people often go oh well 48 divided
by two um it's 24 or they'll they'll
sort of plot some kind of curve in their
mind and they'll say oh maybe it's like
32 or something but of course the actual
answer is
47 days because the patch is doubling in
size every day so it's half full the day
before you get to 48 that's what
exponential growth uh looks like and
we've kind of found that the hard way
now why do people get these things wrong
why do people mess these cognitive
reflection tests up why don't people
look at this and go
there is no right answer but it's got to
be something like 10 000 or 100 000 or a
million the reason it's annoying is we
don't even have the information we need
to give the correct answer but what we
do know is it can't possibly be eight
why can't it be eight because because to
look at that if you look at major
accidents it looks like road a is twice
as dangerous as we could be yeah so we
remember what we've been asked we're
being asked to make these two equivalent
we're being asked to uh to say well how
many minor accidents would it be
for for road layout b to be the
equivalent of road layout a
so well the answer is well it's the same
as how many minor accidents are the
equivalent of 16 minor accidents plus a
thousand extra major accidents right and
the answer is well we don't know but
it's got to be it's got to be at least a
thousand and sixteen it's a bit apples
and oranges though isn't it because like
what's a what's a major accident worth
yeah yeah exactly there's there's no
answer to the question which is why i
say it's the most annoying question in
the world but you don't look at it and
go oh there's not enough there's not
enough information we need we need an
exchange rate of major to minor
accidents what you do is you look at it
you go eight
i mean you might not but an awful lot of
very smart students at yale university
immediately said eight
a whole other bunch not quite as many
said 32 and another bunch not quite as
many said a thousand and sixteen
a thousand and sixteen is maybe just
about right if you say well we're just
going to count accidents and we can't
compare them but really the answer's got
to be
you know a lot way way more than a
thousand and sixteen you know what the
problem with that question is you
straight away forget what you're trying
to solve
you don't you you forget the question
but that's it that's interesting though
isn't it because it's you know i told
you i told you the story we're trying to
compare these layouts we're trying to
figure out you know which which layout
which i know what's the equivalent of
the two layouts and you
daniel kahneman often says when we're
given a difficult question
we often substitute an easy question and
we don't notice that that's what we've
that's that's exactly what i did because
i thought there was a solution i
contrived a question in my head that had
a solution yes absolutely and eight
looks about right i mean you're
absolutely right brady eight is the of
course it's eight of course it's eight
but of course it's not eight it's not
even close to eight so
why do i find these cognitive reflection
um problems interesting it's because my
own interest is in how we think about
statistical claims in the news now when
people see a claim on social media they
see it on twitter on facebook they see a
newspaper headline they see a talking
head on tv how do we think about
those claims how do we process them
and uh it's tempting as a nerd to go
straight to you know the technical
details have they confused correlation
and causation you know have they um is
it within the margin of error all the
sort of statistical questions you might
ask um but actually
very often
what's getting between us and the truth
is our own tendency to leap to
conclusions just as you saw this and
they thought eight that sounds about
right very often we see somebody talking
and we very quickly go yeah that can't
be right that's just fake news what
would you expect you know from those
guys
or instead they go oh yeah yeah that
sounds right this goes to prove i was i
was right all along i always knew that
this government was you know was full of
rogues and villains and and they can't
be trusted with anything i you know i
was having this argument with my friends
in the pub last night in the pub i
remember the pub um i was having this
argument with my friends last night and
this proves i was right and we leap in
with this emotional reaction it was a
really interesting study published i
think about a year ago by gordon
pennycook and a bunch of other
psychologists and gordon penny cook is
interested in fake news and why fake
news spreads and why people spread
misinformation what they found was you
could take a bunch of people who were
say die hard trump supporters
and
show them
a ridiculous claim like 500 migrant
caravans have been intercepted at the
mexican border wearing suicide vests you
know if you show them that claim in the
wild they might well click on it they
might well amplify it like it share it
and you ask them and they'll say yeah
yeah that that is the kind of thing i
might share
if you instead go
just wait a moment
how likely do you think that claim is to
be true there's no judgment do you think
that claim is likely to be true
about 90 of them will go
actually yeah that can't like why would
they be wearing suicide vests why would
why would migrant it doesn't make any
sense none of this makes any sense
and so they're able to see
despite the fact they have a strong you
know view of the world we all have
strong views of the world they're able
to see that that can't be true and yet
at the same time
in a moment of distraction a moment of
inattention
they would they admit that they would
retweet it they would amplify it and i
think i personally wouldn't be
amplifying stuff about migrant caravans
in suicide vests but we all have stuff
that we see
that we we are tempted to retweet
because it fits our biases i can give
you an example um a few years ago i saw
a graph about support for same-sex
marriage personally um i think that's
great news more americans in favor of uh
equal rights for everybody great and i
retweeted this graph which i think was
from a the washington post or a
perfectly decent source
and i tweeted it because of my emotional
reaction like oh that looks right great
tweet 150 000 followers
the very first reply was tim
have you looked at the axes on that
graph
and i hadn't and actually it was a mess
it was they'd done that thing where the
the opinion polls the questions have
been asked um different distances apart
so maybe 10 years would pass and then
they'd ask it twice within one year and
they were all equally spread the whole
thing was a mess i should have clipped
it for my bad data visualization file
but instead i was amplifying it to all
of my followers on twitter because it
just seemed like the kind of thing that
should be true and i wanted it to be
true and i wanted to to share the news
just like this seems like it should be
eight i love these puzzles because i you
know i love
being tricked and falling over my you
know my own feet
mentally i love watching other people
get tricked by funny little puzzles but
there's something deeper going on here
when we're reading the newspapers
looking at social media
we shouldn't be just accepting or
rejecting things because they feel right
because they fit our view of the world
you only need to notice your own
emotions
count to three
have a little think and that is a way to
stop yourself spreading misinformation
if you enjoyed this why not check out
tim harford's book how to make the world
add up it's also out in america under a
different title the data detective or
the data detective if that's how you
like to say it there are links in the
description
and if you like puzzles why not check
out today's episode sponsor brilliant
they've got a site bursting with puzzles
quizzes
interactive courses like the ones you
can see on screen now
all superbly designed to guide you
through the wonderful worlds of
mathematics computers science all sorts
of other stuff
this scientific thinking course already
has my mind buzzing
or why not up your game with some
statistics
it's like a fully equipped gym for your
brain you can get 20 off a premium
subscription by going to brilliant.org
and adding that slash number file again
brilliant.org
number five
i had some delicious toast one bit with
peanut butter and a different beer with
cheese
because you know living the dream